this weekend we lost a very good friend
his name was Rick Ludwig and he was an
NBC executive for 31 years he worked
with such late-night giants as Johnny
Carson David Letterman and Lorne
Michaels and he famously fought
single-handedly to keep a struggling
little show in the air called Seinfeld
that's true story in 1993 when I took
over the late-night show it's a long
time ago but I had a very rocky start
pretty much every one of the network
thought that that I should be cancelled
but one executive disagreed and that was
Rick Ludwin Rick actually came to many
of our early shows and watched what we
were doing he was brutally honest when
he disagreed with our comedy or thought
we'd gone too far but he also saw that
there was a lot of value to what we were
trying to do he was a generous laugher
when we had something good Rick argued
passionately for me with the network and
he helped keep me on the air during
those first two years now yes 16 yeah I
would not be here
sixteen years later during The Tonight
Show Fiasco Ric stuck by me again even
though he was putting his own job at
risk and after I ended up here at TBS
Ric was a regular visitor and he
remained a loyal friend to our show
always very encouraging and full of
great stories Ric Ludwin loved
television and he loved comedy and he
never lost his enthusiasm for the
inspired and the silly he was one of the
most decent and honorable people I've
met in my life
we will all miss him terribly now Ric
was the kind of person who did so much
but unlike most everybody in show
business
Ric didn't go out of his way to try and
get credit so the least I can do for Ric
tonight is show a clip from 2009 in
which Ric gets a special shout-out from
a pretty big guest people just accept
when something's a success and they
think it was always a success
Seinfeld struggled actually remembered
in the early years yeah it's a struggle
three and a half years we were real very
borderline people didn't at NBC were not
excited about the show when we did the
pilot and there was only one guy at NBC
who really did like the idea of his name
was Rick Lauren he was from the late
night and specials department and he's
still with NBC in fact he's here tonight
[Applause]
his reward for saving seinfeld and
making it all happen is to stand and
monitor each one of our shows it wasn't
for him that would be an empty box right
yeah I deserves mentioning a we struggle
to in the first a little longer than you
probably and Rick Levin was one of the
people who stepped in and said I think
the show has potential and he was
eventually proven wrong so thank you
right our our thoughts are with you
tonight Rick and to all of your family
and your friends let's have a big hand
for mr. Strickland